but they kept offering you increasingly
large sums of money to go away didn't
they you're right it went up to about
265 thousand dollars not to appear in
the city right to stay away to get off
my lawn boy but what what they didn't
count on is
when a person
hasn't had that type of money
they really don't miss it in other words
if you haven't ridden in a Rolls-Royce
you don't mind bouncing around in a
Volkswagen it was you don't have that
frame of reference
but more than that I knew that if I sold
it even for five hundred thousand
dollars I knew that after the money was
gone I would become very bitter for
having sold out because my one love was
to at least fail on my own terms I
wanted to see if I could act because all
these bit Parts you're talking about you
really couldn't say this kid had Talent
OR it was just a big fake